Can you explain why we should not just take all our supplements at one time during the day. It is easiest for me to take them all in the morning.
Um, because okay, so there are certain supplements that you could do that.
So your fat soluble supplements, your vitamin A, your vitamin D, your vitamin K, your vitamin E.
You don't have to split those up.
They're, they're fat soluble. They'll stay in your system for a much longer period of time.
You don't have to break those up during the day.
But your other vitamins, your other minerals, your other nutrients that are like herbals.
They have a half life in your body. So if you took them all in the morning,
and let's say the half life was in hour, or you took 100 milligrams of it.
That means in an hour, you only, let's say you absorb 100 milligrams of that supplement.
In an hour, you only have 50 milligrams and another hour, you have 25 milligrams.
Another hour, you have 12.5 milligrams, equals like that.
So by seven, you took about seven o'clock in the morning, by seven o'clock in the night, you have nothing in your system.
Now, if that's the only way you can take your supplements, and you're just being a realist with your own self,
and you just cannot remember just to, to take them at night, then bio means just take them once during the day.
But it is always best, other than your fat soluble supplements to break them up.
The only other supplements that I'd say you, you don't have to do that with,
if you're taking a binder, that would be a supplement that I say, take that in the afternoon, 30 minutes from food,
or in the morning, 30 minutes from food, that's a binder.
So that's not, you're not splitting that up, trying to keep that in circulation.
You're keeping that in the gut, when you're trying to bind things in the gut.
So that's different.
Or taking a digestive enzyme that you're taking with a meal, that's different.
You take that with your meal, you're taking HCl and digestive enzymes with each meal,
because you want it to be there when you're eating.
But if you're trying to kill cancer cells with an herbal supplement,
or you're just taking that general vitamin or whatever, it has a half light.
So the more you are able to split it up, that's something like,
I could do morning and night, that's only two doses.
Is that okay? Yeah, that's better.
And some of you are just fantastic at, oh, I just set by alarm,
but I just have my supplements with me, and I developed this little system,
and I have them in these coaches, and when I take them every three hours,
well, that's great, but some people can't do that.
So just be honest with yourself and do the best.
But there is a reason behind the badness that sometimes,
if you understand the reason, you can be a little bit better
at disciplining yourself to do that, so that helps.